-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden turned 81 today,
despite his campaign staff
specifically advising him
not to.
That's right.
President Biden today
celebrated his 81st birthday,
but not as much
as Republicans did.
President Biden today
presided over the annual
White House turkey pardon.
It may not hold up, though,
because a lot of what they did
were state crimes.
That's right.
President Biden presided
over the White House turkey
pardon,
where he pardoned
Liberty and Bell,
which sounds cute,
but they both broke
into Nancy Pelosi's office
on January 6th.
While introducing a screening
of the new movie "Wonka"
yesterday for military families,
President Biden said
that he wished
he could stay and watch the film
and added, quote,
"I like kids more than adults."
Do you?
"I like kids.
Now please enjoy this film
about famous child murderer
Willy Wonka.
Former President Trump
traveled yesterday
to the southern border,
but they caught him
before he could make it across.
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis' campaign last week
reportedly raised $2 million
in just two days.
And when he found out, DeSantis
could not start smiling.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
said yesterday that former
President Trump is, quote,
"wedded to the teleprompter."
Yeah, his age --
his aides wish.
Here he was this weekend
in Iowa.
-He's not into golden showers,
as they say, they call them.
He's not.
I don't like that idea.
-You think that was
on a teleprompter?
"Make sure we get
golden showers in there."
If Trump's wedded
to a teleprompter,
he's clearly cheating on it.
A library in England
recently received
a copy of Tolkien's World
that was more than
40 years overdue.
It's the first time
in recorded history
that a librarian
has said, "Eh, keep it."
The 19th annual Guinness
World Records Day
was held last week,
beating the previous record
of 18.
I'll stand by it.
I'm not saying you're wrong,
but I'm not saying
I'm wrong either.
Just a classic agree to disagree
and then move on
with the monologue.
The more I talk about it,
the weirder it gets.
But I stand by it.
And finally,
Amazon recently announced
that next year,
customers will be able to browse
and purchase cars
from dealers on their website.
It's the most expensive package
you'll ever have stolen
from your driveway.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We are up and running.